من طرف واحد اعلنت روسيا هدمتها التي لم
تعترف بها اوكرانيا ثم اخذت موسكو تعدد
الخروقات الاوكرانيه اتهم الناطق باسم
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه الجانب الاوكراني
بالاستهداف المدفعي لمناطق سكنيه وعسكريه
روسيه في كل من محور كراسنو لمن ومنطقه
بيلو غروفكا بما تعرف روسيا بجمهوريه
لوغانسكي الشعبيه الى جانب بلده نوفو
بافلوكا بمقاطعه زبرجها فضلنا عن قصف
مدينه دونيسك ثلاث مرات وذلك وفق مركز
الدفاع المشترك الموالي لروسيا بالمقاطعه
قالت روسيا ان الهدنه مرتبطه بالاحتفالات
الشرقيه بعيد الميلاد لكن موالينا لها
نفوا ان تعوق تلك الهدنه الرد على ما
وصافه زعيم الموالي لموسكو بالاستفزازات
الاوكرانيه او ان تكون فرصه لتحسين وضع
الجيش الاخراني ميدانيا قبيل الهدنه
بدقائق اشتعلت خطوط مواجهه وتحديدا في خير
سنه التي قالت الاوكرانيه انها استهدفت
بقصف روسي خلف قتلى وجرحى كما استهدفت
روسيا ايضا وفق الجانب الاوكراني مدنا
وبلدات في محور كوبينسك في مقاطعه خايف
مخلفه اصابات وحرائق لماذا رفضت كييف
الهدنه الروسيه اعتبرها الرئيس الاوكراني
غطاءا تحاول موسكو استخدامه لوقف تقدم
قوات بلاده في الجبهه الشرقيه واكد يوم
الخميس ان السبيل الوحيد لوقف الحرب هو
الانسحاب الروسي من كامل الاراضي
الاوكرانيه الاعراض عن الهدنه الروسيه كان
ايضا راي واشنطن حيث اتهم الرئيس الامريكي
نظيره الروسي بالبحث من خلالها عن متنفس
لها وكذلك كان راي الاتحاد الاوروبي على
لسان مفوض السياسه الخارجيه جوزيف الذي
اعتبر الهدنه الاحاديه محاوله روسيه لشراء
الوقت لاعاده تجميع قوات روسيا واصلاح
سمعتها الدوليه المتضرره الحديث عن ازمه
بوت في الحرب الاوكرانيه لا يظهر في
تصريحات الحلفاء فقط ولكن في حديث
المسؤولين الاوكرانيين الذين يتوعدون بنزع
سلاح روسيا باستخدام الصواريخ حلفائهم
بعيده المدى ويتحدثون عما سيحمله الشتاء
والربيع من بشريات قريبه لمواطنهم ويبلغ
التعويل على الدعم الغربي بوزير الدفاع
الاوكراني حتى يعتبر بلاده باتت الشريكا
وعضوا في حلف النيته بحكم الامر الواقع